hmm
so your character here you are born into
this world figuring yourself out know
thyself one of the most important pieces
of advice know thyself
so who are you who are you what is your
role what is your purpose what is your
mission
what is your North Star what is it
figure it out as quickly as possible
and then wake up everyday pursuing it
why is that being so off you skated has
I've been so lost or forgetting about it
every child is searching for it but some
of the parents haven't even found theirs
and they're trying to file them the kids
into boxes of civilization that they
don't fit in that's why so many people
have so much emotional distress in
today's world who are you why are you
here why did you come here what are you
here to learn
how can you figure it out as quickly as
possible
find other people that have figured out
their purpose ask them questions see if
they can help you the more that we do
that for each other the better our world
will be here we are burst into this
world and the first thing
that we're forgetting to remind everyone
to do is to remember your purpose to
know yourself
surround yourself as quickly as possible
with people that know themselves and
know their purposes and ask them
questions and get to know yourself get
to know your purpose as quickly as
possible
embody that completely into your spirit
and bring it forth every single day
and sometimes when we do this we have to
make sacrifices because so many of the
other things are pulling at our
attention in today's world so we need a
time for us to dedicate to figuring
ourselves out those moments of solitude
that we have do not fill those moments
of solitude with the instant need to
grab a device or take yourself onto the
internet so low down to an inward feel
Who am I why am I here ask yourself that
question close your eyes and feel deeply
into it what do I care about what impact
do I want to make in the world what is
my purpose
do that do that self work do it as
sincerely as genuinely as often as
possible until you start figuring it out
who you are and what your purpose is
and when you start figuring it out and
start going and exploring the areas that
are in the direction of your purpose
look at yourself in the mirror
frequently reflect on your experience
with that is that truly your purpose
keep checking in with yourself and if we
don't find our purpose if we don't know
ourselves in today's world there are so
many other people that want your time
they want your attention they want your
labor they want your creativity and they
want to fuel that for their own
organizations
now you may align with some of their
purposes and it may fill your purpose as
well that is very possible but be
vigilant because if you don't know
yourself and you don't know your purpose
author people will try and come in and
tell you what you should do with your
time
and it also doesn't help that the
moments that were born into the world
that we immediately funnel into the
economic and political hierarchy and
then the thing that we need to do right
away is how do I find myself higher up
on the hierarchy as soon as possible
that's so important because I have to
pay for all of these things with this
thing called money
listen know yourself first and foremost
know yourself because if you forget to
know yourself and you run directly into
the hierarchy you will not know what
you're doing for years and years at a
time
now those lessons these lessons when we
become more conscious we become more
aware we say who really am I why have I
been doing that for years
unconsciously I've been doing that it's
not even me it's not even Who I am it's
not even my purpose it's not my
Northstar those are the lessons those
lessons are precious that's not
something to be angry at yourself about
that something to embody is something
deeply spiritual that you've learned
you've learned that now share that share
that with other people hey I was not
living consciously for a couple years I
wasn't doing things that were aligned
with my purpose now I'm talking to
younger people and I'm making sure that
those younger people don't do the same
thing I'm making sure that those younger
people pursue their purposes as quickly
as possible that's so important these
are the lessons that we can share with
other people so do share who are you
what is your purpose share that with
other people go and talk to more people
your family talk to them about it
sometimes there's a misalignment they
say that no we don't want you to pursue
that we want you to pursue something
that makes money and if that's the case
then maybe it's important for you to
take a moment to reflect on
if I should be sharing so much of this
with my family now maybe I should be
sharing more of it with my friends for
now who are those people that you can
find around you that know their purpose
that know their North Star that can help
you that can help you further pursue
your purpose find them as quickly as
possible talk to them inspire other kids
to do the same thing a lot of the time
our parents brought us into this world
we came through our parents into this
world that doesn't necessarily mean that
every single thing that we're going to
align with our parents about especially
what our purpose or our North Star
mission ISM those are our tests of faith
sometimes when your parents challenge
you
those are your tests of faith how
faithful are you to that North Star that
you're doing because you will get tested
and those are the challenges that your
character goes through you identify with
the North Star and you pursue it and
you'll have challenges those are your
lessons we have to remember that
get talking to more people about knowing
yourself about them knowing themselves
who are they what is their purpose what
is their North Star what is your purpose
and your North Star
ask these questions more often this is
how we can best live our fullest life
thank you for watching I appreciate it